things have just gone so well for you it
success yeah these these tours are doing
are so popular the latest one the tour
is called 50 yes sir you you are 50 are
you you feeling different right now is
it your time for you no I turned 50 and
I just decided to call the tour that red
I'm kind of going the opposite of all
the people who do like the Botox and the
hair plugs and try to look 22 for the
rest of their life right you know when
they really just you know they don't
look good yeah you know you're saying
why don't fake it just embrace it
embrace your eyes water when you look at
them my wife's always watching like
those Real Housewives and stuff and they
just look exhausted
they're like an F it you don't know what
always reminds me I remember when Brett
Favre played on the Vikings yeah we're
just like just retired dude you're in
the Hall of Fame yeah yeah it's over and
those women it's like yeah you had your
time you were beautiful and it's over so
you wrote you don't remember when you
were a kid you went to the club and
there was that older person hanging out
that creep yeah that's what you're doing
that's what you're doing
Fifty's not the new 40 it's 50 don't see
doctors yeah
I have to have blood taken so I feel I
feel young physically but mentally like
when I watch TV it makes me feel old
what makes you feel about watching TV ah
this well music there's no guitar solos
anymore and then for some reason with
all this technology Millennials if you
take a full water bottle and you flip it
in the air and it lands upright they run
out of the room like they just saw which
[Applause]
it's like really yet virtual reality
glasses on you're playing all these
video games and all somebody has to do I
mean that's like a game like Tom Sawyer
would have played so it's stuff like
that that I most like I'm not I'm not
ridiculing it it's just like why I can't
relate to this you can't relate to it
you